et aujourd'hui nous sommes en 2015 et je
vais vous parler de la femme parfaite
parce qu'en 2015 nous sommes toutes
parfaites
tous les matins vous révélions il ya un
coffret de maquillage alain vizier bien
chaussé épiler avec un mari parfait une
maison parfaitement rangé nous sommes en
2015 nous sommes des femmes de magazines
ou pas plus sérieusement on peut pas
être parfaite partout
par contre moi je vais vous donner
aujourd'hui trois conseils pour devenir
super roumanie c'est possible premier
conseil faire ce qu'on aime
alors quand je dis faire ce qu'on aime
c'est carrément l'expression trouver un
travail que vous aimez et vous n'aurez
plus jamais à travailler dans votre vie
et la première question que j'ai à vous
poser là dessus sur ce sujet avez vous
déjà fait un bilan dans votre vie par
pas un bilan comptable pas un bilan
professionnel internes aux entreprises
ont fait semblant de dire oui dans trois
à cinq ans je serai encore là non un
bilan sur soi mon premier bilan
je les fais à 26 ans je vous explique le
contexte j'ai grandi à l'île de la
réunion
la ravine des cabris j'ai fait une
classe prépa et je suis allé en
métropole à paris pour faire une école
d'ingénieur puis j'ai enchaîné sur une
école de commerce un master spécialisé
et j'ai trouvé un job le job bien payé à
paris sur les champs-elysées avec des
supers collègues
super
au bout de deux ans je suis arrivé à ce
qu'on appelle au niveau zéro de la
confiance en soi le moment on se lève
tous les matins où pleure
on rentre le soir dans les transports en
commun on essaye de pas montrer aux
autres aux autres complaire le matin
vous n'utilisez où je voyais mon manager
et je lui disais mais oui tu as raison
je suis nul
tu as raison de balancer ses feuilles au
visage me disant tu es lui enfin moi
c'est ce que j'entendais en tout cas et
là je me suis posé des question j'ai
fait mon premier bilan
parce que j'ai quand même fait six ans
d'études
j'ai trouvé un super boulot qui me
plaisait à priori et j'en arrive là au
moment où plus rien ne va je n'existe
même plus loin et j'ai commencé à me
poser des questions et un poser des
questions et à me poser des questions et
un jour je suis tombé sur un livre qui
s'appelle l'homme qui voulait être
heureux de laurent gounelle que je vous
conseille laurent gounelle dans ce livre
explique en fait il ne dit pas qu est ce
que vous pouvez faire dans la vie il dit
qu'est ce que vous aimez faire
qu'est-ce que vous avez concrètement
envie de faire et ça m'a trotté dans la
tête
plusieurs mois parce que ça se fait pas
tout de suite et un jour un midi j'étais
avec une collègue en train de faire du
shopping après après avoir mangé
déjeuner avant de remonter dans les
bureaux de l'immeuble et entre deux
robes de l'isie sis en fait moi ce que
j'aimerais vraiment faire c'est rentré
de la rénommée est monté ma boîte dans
le recrutement
et depuis ce jour là plus aucun matin
n'a été le même parce que j'ai formulée
ce que j'avais là ce que j'avais envie
de faire ce que j'aimais faire
finalement et vraiment je vous conseille
de faire le même bilan et d'en arriver
là au point d'exprimer ce qui a au fond
de vous parce que vraiment le lendemain
matin c'est plus du tout la même
et ça appuie t la même chose depuis 2012
ça c'est mon premier conseil et je crois
que on l'a vu dans d'autres talk
aujourd'hui faites ce que vous aimez
vraiment c'est important mon deuxième
conseil travail est toujours rentable
c'est ma façon à moi de dire soyez
féminine accepter votre féminité
quand j'ai continué ce parcours avec
enfin la conviction que j'avais trouvé
ce qu'il fallait que je fasse dans la
vie j'ai commencé à travailler sur moi
sur la présentation
parce que finalement réunionnais est ce
que j'étais je m'étais embourbé dans la
mode parisienne qui à partir du mois
d'octobre se transforme en noir gris
marron aubergines d'autres voilà il me
manquait en fête des couleurs et j'ai
accepté ça et j'ai commencé à mettre des
couleurs en en face on habille et j'ai
commencé à refaire miniser ma façon
d'être finalement et la housse et ses
rangs sera là ça s'est ressenti ça a été
dans le travail du jour au lendemain
j'ai des managers qui sont venus me voir
qui m'ont fait à la bombe le super
continuer comme ça bon je mets des
boucles d'oreilles
vraiment et le lendemain j'avais des
clients qui disais à mes managers mais
alors elle est super il faut trop pour
la garde pour la prochaine mission ce
qui a rendu directeur très très content
et je me suis rendu compte de ce
changement dans tous les jours il ya la
première partie où j'ai dit ce que je
voulais faire dans la vie
la deuxième partie où j'ai changé parce
que j'ai commencé à exprimer à
l'extérieur ce que j'avais en moi et ça
s'est ressenti autour et ça a continué à
se ressentir quand en 2013 je suis venu
à l'île de la réunion parce que j'ai
trouvé un job pas la réunion qui était
dans la logique pour moi de mon parcours
professionnel et qui allait m'amener
j'espère j'espérais en ce temps-là à
l'entrepreneuriat et quand je suis
arrivé pour la première fois au
rendez-vous qu'on appelle réseautage
donc les rendez-vous rencontre d'autres
professionnels sur l'île et bien comme
je travaille dans le monde du numérique
les professionnels sur l'île ce sont des
costards cravate chemise cravate et moi
je suis arrivé avec une jupe et des
talons et dans n'a pas loupé dans le bon
sens du terme
parce que pour le coup une femme dans le
numérique ça arrive pas souvent une
femme qui en plus met de la couleur et
montrent qu'elle existe eh ben on s'en
souvient quand on la revoit et ça c'est
important
en tout cas dans un métier de
représentation et dont je pense tous vos
métiers vous mettez votre féminité en
avant c'est important même quand vous
travaillez dans le btp vous pouvez être
maquillée et s'il faut mettre un casque
vraiment ch en tenir je demande aux
néons conseil finalement aller faire du
shopping
c'est vrai quoi exprimer exprimez vous
dans ce que vous êtes tous les jours et
je sais que ceux qui me connaissent ici
diront que c'est vrai c'est ce que je
fais tous les jours mon troisième
conseil
les trois hommes mus avec des quads
assumez votre réussite
et là je sais qu'en général j'aime
beaucoup parler de sheryl sandberg comme
on a vu la vidéo tout le monde est au
même niveau
moi j'ai retenu quelque chose de très
importante cette femme d'abord sheryl
sandberg c'est la numéro 2 de facebook
facebook tu me connais tout le monde
connaît mark zuckerberg
elle est juste en dessous et c'est une
femme est dans les propos qu allah dans
le ted qu'on a vu juste avant elle
explique à une chose très importante sur
les femmes vis-à-vis du succès elle dit
une femme quand on lui demandera est a
fait du beau boulot comme angers
explique ta réussite
elle répondra quand j'ai travaillé dur
ça a été dur
ou alors mon équipe a été là
heureusement mon équipe a été là on a
réussi son ensemble ou alors tu es de la
chance et c'est là que pour nous poser
un homme dira m brasse je suis génial
j'ai réussi moi et ça c'est ce que met
on pas les femmes aujourd'hui et c'est
ce qui manque
moi je vous dis aujourd'hui j'ai réussi
je suis à deux mois déposé les statuts
d'une entreprise
tout ça prend du temps bien sûr mais
mais j'ai suivi petit à petit des trois
conseils que je vous donne aujourd'hui
il y en a sept autres à vrai dire est ce
que j'aimerais vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est enfin fait un bilan sur vous même
c'est important même aujourd'hui deux
mois même si vous l'avez déjà fait hier
fait un bilan c'est important de savoir
vous en êtes deux aller faire du
shopping ça je pense que c'est lui
conseille le plus simple que vous êtes
amenés aujourd'hui et 3 aller faire la
fête
vraiment quand vous réussissez quelque
chose allait le partager avec les autres
parce que finalement c'est ça c'est le
mot vous partager avec les autres vous
vivez complètement ce que vous avez
réussi ce que vous avez pu accomplir
jusqu'à ce moment là et ce sont ces
trois petites choses qui tous les jours
on vous apporté beaucoup de bonheur et
ce sont ces trois petites choses qui
vont faire que du point de vue extérieur
quand les gens vous regardent et ils
vont vous dire toi tu es une superbe
brune